da sind zum dritten mal
wie ist die lage ließ die lage die lage
die lage kommt 25 erster und was hat
sich für dich letztes jahr getan
münchen letzten jahres ausführlich getan
hat eine sehr schwere zeit gehabt
im letzten jahr oder als letztes jahr
oder das davor das ja also das jahr
davor 2011 war ein bisschen anstrengend
ging auf die knochen
das waren auf der autobahn
viel unterwegs wir müssen auf die psyche
als anstrengend war weil ich die
konzerte und parallel noch ein album zu
machen musste dort programmstunden und
et cetera und bla bla bla und dann kam
2012 des anfang des jahres war die tour
halt ich halte mich viel so vor der tour
also kultur natur mensch und dann kam
das album schon wieder ist was jetzt
herauskommt war schon düsseldorf
aufgenommen fünf monate lang und habe
jetzt alles gut weihnachten geburtstag
und silvester school festgestellt habe
auch in unseren interviews super lock
polarisiert wahnsinnig polarisieren
heißt die einen finden sich sensationell
und die anderen finden dich grauen wie
kommt das ich weiß nicht wo es keine
ahnung ich bin letzten interview
champagner gewesen kann das sein wo sie
ja da bekommen ja ja ich aggressiv mache
keine ahnung wenn ich zum beispiel
unterwegs bin und die leute fakten ich
habe also es gibt ja auch coole fans so
von mir aber ich bin ja in deutschland
unterwegs da kann manchmal so setzen von
überschreiten
nur weil es nicht mit den dasitzen und
den er jetzt eine halbe stunde laufen
und da ich weiter muss weil ich zu tun
habe
antwort wenn die personen das selber mal
wenn du mich versuchen zu testen zum
beispiel hannover am steintor läuft am
steintor um und war gerade essen da
kommen besucher kommen muss jetzt einen
getränkehalter schön strecken und dann
wenn es dann so weit geht und sagen
alter fick deine mutter die hohen so
interesse hat mich diese scheiß egal ob
meine musik oder nicht müssen so der
textinhalt kennen sie das ist ein spiel
sind
da kommt rein sehen oder es hat zwar
wasser ist kein sinn es ist ein action
fans verkauft ok wird ja aber daraus
kann sind der glaube dass zum beispiel
das französische wunderbar und die ganze
draufgehen
ich möchte auch gerne aber ich feiere
das musikalisch wasser nachzuweisen und
die leute es gibt leute die mich
verstehen aber die feier musikalisch
aber es gibt leute die das nicht
verstehen und das musikalischen sparen
und trotzdem auf meine seite um point
clicks geben warum schenkt mir geld
beginnt mit wenn ihr nicht unsympathisch
findet und meine musik gefeiert
ich hätte auch jedes mal geld berlin es
gibt so schwachsinn was ihr macht so
richtig läuft in den kommentaren auf
michael okay weil ich schlafen konnte
ja gibt's nicht mal so ein schlag in die
magengrube
oder denkst der hat sich getan hast du
manchmal lustige sätze der auch die über
müssten so setzten den weg sind schon
mal lustig was sie gar nicht schlecht
sind die sind teilweise auch aber nutzer
mit
landloser kunden
oder abschieben und so den ersten satz
oder wenn ich merke klappt zunächst kann
man damit einschlafen oder ist das ja
schlafen im babyalter guckst du auf die
klamotten schmuck
ich denke es gibt leute die haben echt
siebenstellige summen verzockt in bayern
verzockt ja nicht verfolgt option
sichern
ja aber ich sehe eine siebenstellige
sechs stelle kam es aufgeben ist auf
jeden fall aber das kurhotel bad dies
nicht nur vorurteile partys überhaupt
halte
düsseldorf 100 riesen losgehen
mit 15 das kind das im palast nach
freiheit schreit
du bist kugeln die gerade fliegt auf
mein leid ich bin der vater der michael
raab zu aller ruft nun lüge wie in eine
weiße die freiheitsstatue
ich bin der immigranten niederland der
asyl will der dealer der mir sagt das
kokain hat ich bin der mann den keiner
hand halten not du nur der scheiß
gedanke griff zum alkohol
ich bin das kind in afrika das camp für
sein brot du der kapitalist der profit
schreckensjahr druck nach oben und ich
weiß nicht ob meine seele kriegst du ich
bin und bleibe suchen von gott das ist
schon gedicht alter das ist dann wieder
der erwachsene haft und der haft wird
jetzt erwachsener auf jeden fall
und sobald ihr geld als cool
super vielen dank